winter is coming but not everybody's
gonna live to see it first of his name
I'm just saying I'm fun this is another
stellar episode on the heels of already
a really good episode we're getting
things continuing to build overall in
terms of the season but we also get a
lot of nice little nuggets and a
resolution on a couple of fronts with a
number of things and that's really nice
and rewarding too in terms of what's
going on in King's Landing I really got
a single out seriously in this episode
and it's been a long time since she's
had moments where I really found her
interesting mostly she's just a Raging
[ __ ] and she's really good at it don't
get me wrong but we got a little deeper
this time we got more of an insight into
how she really feels about Joffrey and
how she feels about her just her
situation and everything she's in and we
get that little depth of she is human
she is a mother and she has the feelings
and the emotions of a mother she's
damaged beyond repair but it's nice just
to get that slightly softer side tour
cuz we haven't gotten it in a while we
get to stop in at the Vale which we
haven't been at since season 1 and you
know what she's still crazy and her
son's still creepy so it feels like
everything we've seen is is relevant and
it wasn't just a one note thing you know
we just had it there for that one cool
scene with Tyrion in the first season
know the stuff we'll come back it's all
relevant and I like that feeling over
across the Narrow Sea they do something
interesting with Daenerys but I kind of
don't like it either they sort of give a
better sense of really what it is she's
managing to accomplish and how well
she's really getting what she wants to
get done and fortunately they then
immediately set up something else for
her to deal with that will keep her even
longer where she is and keep her from
coming across the sea and dealing with
Westeros and the specific thing that it
is it it's earned it makes sense but
it's just one more reason that we're
gonna have to wait for her to come over
and do her thing over on Westeros with
her dragons and it's what we're all
waiting for you know what this episode
gives us which is I think it's just nice
to see in it in a world this dirty and
corrupt and twisted as the world of this
story is it's nice to have a night
I'll request Brianna charged perfect for
that
and I'm already loving preparing with
Podrick highlight of this episode those
definitely what's going on up north of
the wall and again avoiding spoilers
can't talk too much about it but I will
say this there are I'm gonna call three
really nice kills in this episode and
when I say nice I just mean my reaction
was oh yeah and that's not necessarily
has to do with who gets killed that's
part of it but part of it is just the
way that they're done they're just
really enjoyable kills and I know that
sounds really morbid but they were kind
of that enjoyable killing that are in
that horror movie kind of way when you
go to save to Friday the 13th then you
just want to see some really cool kills
there's some really cool kills in this
episode hey I could be morbid - there's
nothing wrong with that if they're gonna
have good kills I'm gonna single them
out and say good job trying to think if
there was anything else to tell
Oh Baelish again can't go into details
but the depth of this guy and I don't
mean depths is in layers I mean death
says in how far will he sink oh my god
this guy I feel my skin crawl when he's
on screen which is awesome as I said
just a really positive building steam
episode with just some great buttons to
end it on just really good moments that
you you and you're gonna enjoy so here's
a question for you what was the most
satisfying kill in this series so far
for you the the one that when the
character died you just went yeah I have
a hunch I know what it's gonna be for
most people but not gonna say it here I
want you to tell me drop a comment down
below and we'll talk about it and until
next time this council is adjourned